bonjour antoine la russie reste donc sur
le qui vive dans une région toujours
sous tension oui tout à fait et même si
la russie a ordonné le retrait de ses
troupes de la frontière ukrainienne et
bien les tensions restent vives tout le
long de la frontière occidentale de la
russie les autorités russes garde en
particulier un oeil sur les activités
militaires de l'otan dans la région
écoutez en réponse aux activités
militaires menaçante de l'otan nous
avons pris des mesures appropriées
comme vous le savez une inspection
surprise des capacités opérationnelles
des armes et des districts militaire
ouest et sud a été effectuée vous armer
trois formations de troupes aéroportées
ont été efficacement transféré à la
frontière occidentale dans les zones des
missions d'entraînement et de combat
étant rares ont été ceux qui n'ont pas
adhéré au coeur puisse en blâmant la
russie pour la moindre raison d'abord
nous n'aimons pas les exercices
militaires sur notre sol puis nous
sommes
irrité par leur retrait vers leurs bases
permanentes et certains ont décidé de
nous mettre en garde contre les
conséquences de notre activité sur notre
propre territoire
je tiens à le souligner nous n'acceptons
pas ce type d'avertissement et nous
envisageons de faire par la suite tout
ce qui sera nécessaire pour assurer la
sécurité de nos frontières ou chesnais
de friendly
en effet l'otan organise jusqu'au mois
de juin de vastes manoeuvres dans tout
l'est de l'europe ce qui n'est pas pour
plaire à moscou un haut niveau de
tension qui se ressent également en mer
noire en mer noire avec le déploiement
de bâtiments de guerre britannique qui
est prévu dans les prochaines semaines
malgré tout la volonté de dialogue
existe le président ukrainien a même
proposé à venir poutine de se rencontrer
directement dans le donbass le kremlin a
bien accueilli cette nouvelle même s'il
ne faut pas se tromper sur les résultats
à attendre de cette possible rencontre
d'écouté on ne peut toujours que salué
l' envie de discuter
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
le directeur adjoint de l'administration
présidentielle une cause ac est en
contact permanent avec celle du
président ukrainien
c'est à dire avec le président ukrainien
troisième chose le président a
clairement précisé son attitude envers
l'initiative de discuter dans le
contexte du contenu possible d'un tel
dialogue en évoquant que ce genre de
dialogue ne pourrait porter que sur les
sujets les relations bilatérales
ce dialogue ne peut donc pas avoir pour
base des objectifs de résolution du
conflit dans le sud est de l'ukraine la
russie n'est pas partie à ce conflit
moscou est il persuadé que la seule
mesure correcte pour le règlement et la
mise en oeuvre des dispositions de
l'ensemble des mesures de minsk et
d'établissement d'un dialogue direct
avec les représentants et
l'administration des deux républiques
autoproclamées la situation dans le
donbass à d'ailleurs été évoqué entre
vladimir poutine et emmanuel macron hier
soir lors d'une conversation
téléphonique le président russe a un à
ce passage à ce moment souligné
l'importance d'établir un dialogue
direct entre le pouvoir ukrainien d'une
part et les responsables politiques des
républiques autoproclamées de lougansk
et de deux nièces qu d'autre part selon
lui c'est la seule façon de pouvoir
apaiser la situation dans cette région
merci beaucoup antoine gayraud pour
toutes ces précisions depuis moscou